pensemos en el mercado de inmuebles de
cierta ciudad en el eje vertical y
gráfica de la renta en términos del
dinero por metro cuadrado por mes y en
el eje horizontal se encuentran los
metros cuadrados disponibles al mes en
millones ese es un millón 2 millones 3
millones 4 millones y 5 millones en azul
tenemos la curva de demanda podemos ver
que mientras el precio es alto la
demanda por metro cuadrado es baja y
conforme el precio baja la demanda por
los metros cuadrados aumenta pero lo que
me quiero enfocar en este vídeo es ver
la curva de demanda como la curva del
beneficio marginal así que cuando
tenemos este primer metro cuadrado
incremental que se agrega al mercado va
a tener un enorme beneficio marginal
todos están desesperados por tener un
lugar que puedan rentar y en el que
puedan vivir así que por eso tiene un
gran beneficio marginal y conforme van
aumentando los metros cuadrados el
beneficio marginal va disminuyendo de la
misma manera podemos ver la curva de la
oferta y esta sería la curva del costo
marginal
así que el costo marginal en este primer
metro cuadrado para los que lo están
ofreciendo para los caseros va a costar
un dólar por metro cuadrado y otra forma
de verlo es que para este primer metro
cuadrado aunque no sabemos cuál sería su
precio suponiendo que su precio fuera de
tres dólares cantidad que estoy
inventando la realidad sería de que este
precio para este primer metro cuadrado
de tres dólares sería un buen incentivo
para que alguien haga o produzca este
primer metro cuadrado ya que el costo es
de solo un dólar y no pueden rentar a
tres dólares y también hay el incentivo
para que alguna persona lo rente ya que
el beneficio marginal aquí es de cuatro
dólares y sólo tienen que pagar tres
dólares así que esta transacción va a
realizarse siempre y cuando el precio se
encuentre entre 1 y 4 dólares pero
ustedes pueden imaginarse viendo cómo
dibujamos esto dónde está el punto de
equilibrio los proveedores van a estar
agregando cada vez más metros cuadrados
que se van a aumentar hasta el punto en
el que el beneficio marginal se vuelve
igual al costo marginal así que aquí el
beneficio marginal es igual al costo
marginal no tendría caso que los
productores hicieran otro metro cuadrado
incremental después de este punto ya que
si lo hacen el costo marginal de este
metro cuadrado adicional va a ser mayor
que el beneficio marginal que se puede
obtener de éste si el costo es mayor que
el beneficio nadie va a rentar ese metro
cuadrado extra así que alcanzamos el
equilibrio en 2 millones de metros
cuadrados por mes en el mercado a un
precio de 3 dólares por metro cuadrado
al mes podemos ver todo este sobrante o
excedente en este escenario del
equilibrio vemos que el sobrante o el
excedente del consumidor por este metro
cuadrado incrementar las personas están
dispuestos a pagar cuatro dólares por
metro cuadrado pero lo pueden pagar a
tres dólares
el siguiente pagará un poquito menos
dólares y el beneficio sigue siendo de
sólo tres dólares así sucesivamente
hasta llegar a este punto de acá así que
el área de este triángulo que estoy
sombreando es el excedente o el sobrante
del consumidor
sobrante del consumidor
y lo podemos calcular este es un
triángulo y aquí todas estas curvas de
demanda son líneas tenemos la altura de
uno una base de dos por lo que el área
será la mitad de uno por dos lo que será
igual a un millón de dólares
multiplicamos un dólar por dos millones
y lo dividimos a la mitad así que
tenemos un excedente del consumidor de
un millón de dólares ahora veamos el
excedente o el sobrante del productor el
sobrante o excedente del productor va a
ser esta área de aquí este primer metro
cuadrado incremental solo costó un dólar
pero los productores lo pueden rentar
por tres dólares y seguirán produciendo
más y más metros cuadrados hasta que
lleguen a los dos millones de metros
cuadrados ya que antes de este punto
esos metros cuadrados van a poder rentar
los por más de lo que les costó
producirlos así que el área de este
triángulo es el sobrante del productor
y esto también lo podemos calcular esta
altura de aquí es de 22 dólares y esta
base de acá es de 2 millones 2 x 2 y el
resultado a la mitad nos va a dar 2
millones de dólares así que el sobrante
del productor es igual a 2 millones de
dólares
si queremos conocer el excedente o
sobrante total va a ser uno más dos es
de tres millones de dólares ahora este
precio de renta en equilibrio de tres
dólares es bastante caro por ejemplo mi
departamento anterior tenía dos cuartos
y dos baños queda de mil metros
cuadrados por lo que tendría que pagar
tres mil dólares al mes de renta y es
una renta bastante alta digamos que las
personas comienzan a quejarse de estas
rentas tan altas y lo que dice el
gobierno es que bueno esa renta es muy
cara no es justo y vamos a poner un
límite a esto así que va a implementarse
un control de precios un control en el
precio de la renta
simplificando de más este escenario para
poder usar este modelo de aquí digamos
que el gobierno de la ciudad establece
un control de renta en el metro cuadrado
por mes así que tendrán un tope de
precio en esta renta de dos dólares por
metro cuadrado por mes y veamos qué es
lo que sucede aquí si se tiene este tope
de precio aquí en dos dólares dado esto
qué va a suceder y lo que quiero que
pensemos es cuál será el nuevo sobrante
del consumidor y el nuevo sobrante del
productor y los invito a que detengan el
vídeo y piensa en un momento ustedes en
ello veamos qué sucede desde el punto de
vista del productor no tiene ningún
sentido para ellos que produzcan más de
un millón de unidades o de un millón de
metros cuadrados al mes o más que
producir y rentar más de un millón de
metros cuadrados al mes ya que esos
metros cuadrados extra por encima de
esto su costo marginal será mayor que el
beneficio marginal
y que los productores se van a detener
aquí así que el excedente o sobrante del
productor va a ser el área de este
pequeño triángulo de acá y acá hay uno
un dólar por un millón a la mitad el
nuevo excedente o sobrante del productor
será ahora que está el control de renta
medio millón de dólares o 500 mil
dólares 500 mil dólares así que con esto
vemos que este control de renta impacta
negativamente a los productores ya que
su excedente baja dramáticamente bueno
ahora qué pasará con el excedente o
sobrante del consumidor aquí estamos
hablando de un millón de unidades o un
millón de metros cuadrados al mes así
que el nuevo excedente del consumidor es
esta área de acá por lo que pueden ver
que al menos en este primer metro
incremental los consumidores se están
beneficiando un poco más de ellos para
encontrar el área total de esto vamos a
dividirla en dos partes este punto es un
millón de metros cuadrados al mes
que le corresponden tres y medio dólares
por metro cuadrado por mes y eso lo
podemos usar para calcular la nueva área
que estoy señalando con este otro color
el área de este pequeño triángulo tiene
una altura de punto cinco y una base de
uno y todo esto se va a dividir a la
mitad así que esta parte de 15 era 250
mil y esta área de aquí abajo tiene una
altura de 1.5 una base de 11.5 dólares
por metro cuadrado por mes por un millón
de metros cuadrados al mes así que a
esto le sumamos a esto 1.5 millones y el
sobrante o excedente total del
consumidor el sobrante del consumidor
será hora de 1.75 millones así que este
sobrante del consumidor sin duda aumento
ya que le ganó todo esto al productor
pero pensemos que está sucediendo ahora
en nuestra sociedad en nuestra ciudad
ahora el productor no quiere a rentar
más metros cuadrados y pareciera que
hemos perdido un sobrante total debido a
esto nuestra ciudad perdió este
excedente sobrante correspondiente a
toda esta área que podemos calcularla al
restar el nuevo sobrante total o
excedente de aquel excedente sobrante
que calculamos al principio antes de que
existiera un control de renta antes el
excedente total era de 3 millones los 2
millones del excedente del productor más
el millón del excedente del consumidor
era de 3 millones y después del control
de renta el excedente del consumidor más
el excedente del productor que nos da a
2.25 millones así que lo que perdimos 3
- 2.25 la diferencia es de 750 mil
dólares
y esto es mensual esta área de aquí
representa la pérdida del excedente
total y éstos 750 mil dólares al mes se
conocen como pérdida de peso muerto así
que se puede debatir con respecto a este
control de renta si es bueno es malo
quién se beneficia de esta dinámica y
sin duda esta es una gran simplificación
de cómo existe esta situación realmente
pero este modelo nos ayuda a pensar y
reflexionar sobre lo que le sucede al
excedente total cuando se implementan
este tipo de control de precios